We were asked to help a global bank customer
that had spent two years developing an application
meant to be used by their tellers across their bank branches.
That thousands of business users across hundreds of branches
worldwide, were seeing performance problems.
When the customer has a problem, even though it's in code that they wrote
that's still on top of our product
so we certainly jump in and help.
There were a lot of issues, and they escalated to our team, the SWAT Team
to come in and give an assist.
Digital Business Automation SWAT Team is a little like a real SWAT team
we're a quick response, reactive team that brings deep technical skills across all of our products
to solve the customer's issue as quickly as possible.
Any customer that's experiencing a difficult issue has access to the SWAT Team.
What we’re looking for is to really dig down into the problem
and get real, hands-on information to see
where we can help and what we can do to best help the customer.
You start when the customer starts, and you don't finish until the customer is done for the day.
So, it might be a 12-hour or a 16-hour day, it's whatever it takes.
A problem like this, it's important to look at the entirety of the application.
We want to look at the hardware it's running on
we want to look at the operating system they're using
the database, and how they've developed their UI.
And it was important for our team to come in and we were able to get them down to five seconds.
One of the great things about working in IBM Support is every customer situation brings a new problem.
And I know, based on our experience, that
we're going to solve that problem and we're going to get the customer to where they want to be.